-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
I'm going to get to the news.
During his remarks at
Saturday's White House
correspondents' dinner,
President Biden said,
"American democracy
is not a reality show."
And he's right.
Reality shows get
much better ratings.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating has increased
slightly
over the last two months,
and now the White House
is scrambling like hell
to figure out what he did.
"Did he change his hair?
A different mask?
What tie was he wearing?"
That's right, President Biden's
approval rating
has increased to 42%.
He now ranks slightly above
leaf blowers.
[ Laughter ]
At his rally in Nebraska
yesterday,
former president Trump appeared
to misremember Ohio Republican
Senate candidate
J.D. Vance's name
and called him J.D. Mandel.
That's bad enough, but then he
said, "J.D. Mandel will win
or my name isn't Donald Vance."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll, just
35% of college students said
they like Elon Musk more than
other megabillionaires.
Said Musk, "Oh, yeah?
How much to buy college?"
[ Laughter ]
"Not just yours.
The whole idea."
[ Laughter ]
After the share price of Meta
increased by over 17% last week,
CEO Mark Zuckerberg became $11
billion wealthier in one day.
Then that became $12 billion
when he stuck his hand
in the pocket of a hoodie
he hadn't worn in a while.
[ Laughter ]
"Ooh, that's fortuitous."
A couple recently got married on
a Southwest flight to Las Vegas
and then immediately started
watching different movies.
[ Laughter ]
It deserved better.
That's a wonderful joke.
I didn't think it would go well.
[ Laughter ]
But it was too good not to do.
A lot of you aren't married yet,
but you're going to be,
and then one day you're going to
be lying in bed
and you're going to realize how
[bleep] funny that joke was.
[ Laughter ]
I'm willing -- You know what?
I'm willing to make
that investment now.
[ Laughter ]
Equity. That joke has equity.
That's right.
A couple recently got married on
a Southwest flight to Las Vegas,
and like most couples
who go to Vegas,
decided to get divorced
on the flight back.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
more than half of Americans want
their family to have access
to their personal phone
and computer data
after they die.
The other half are men.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a single lottery
ticket was sold in Arizona
last week that won the
$473 million Powerball jackpot,
and the big winner was --
Aw, damn it!
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.